hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute zeige ich euch unsere nannte
schrank also kleiderschrank und ich
zeige euch in diesem video ein paar
tipps und tricks wie ihr viel platz
sparen könnt wie aber trotzdem alles
übersichtlich ist und noch ein paar
wäsche tipps das mache in diesem video
in unserer alten wohnung da hatten wir
den kleiderschrank der war so etwa drei
meter langen morath und nicht wir haben
uns den geteilt und walter uns dann ein
bisschen zu knapp wurde haben wir dann
noch eine kommode dazu genommen kommunen
finde ich immer ganz praktisch und das
sag ich euch auch jetzt und zeigt euch
das auch jetzt im video denn ich finde
alles was in schubladen ist wirklich am
übersichtlichste und wir haben sie
überlegt ok den kleiderschrank lassen
weil in der alten wohnung wenn wir
umziehen haben wir sowieso ein ganz
neues schlafzimmer und ihr habt ja schon
das schlafzimmer video gesehen
das heißt ja wir da vorne das bett und
im prinzip nur ein sideboard und dann
die band und hinter der wand ist eben
hier diese an kleiderschrank und den
haben wir uns wirklich konfigurieren
lassen
also überlegt ihr euch am besten was
habe ich denn überhaupt ein klamotten es
gibt ja menschen frauen die tragen viele
kleider und röcke dann gibt es frauen
die tragen will ich gar keine kleider
und haben mehr hosen und oberteile
blusen oder pullover und da kann man
sich wirklich im vorfeld schon überlegen
was hat man also eine bestandsaufnahme
das habe ich mit dem rad auch gemacht
bei murat ist eigentlich ganz einfach
der hat t-shirts polo-shirts im
schwarzpulver hosen lang und kurz und
unterwerfung was man eben noch so hat
bei mir war das ganze ein bisschen
durchmischter und so habe ich uns
wirklich eine liste gemacht bin damit
dann einfach ins möbelhaus wir sind da
zum xxx lutz nach karlsruhe haben wir
nämlich auch alle unsere anderen möbel
her und dann haben uns gedacht okay da
wohl bisher auch immer ganz gut beraten
und da holen wir eben auch den
kleiderschrank die erste große frage die
uns beschäftigt hat war nehmen wir einen
kleiderschrank mit türen ohne türen mit
schiebetüren mit normalen türen damen
uns wächst ein bisschen umgeguckt und
ich muss dazu sagen wir haben schon ein
bisschen erfahrung unser allererstes
schlafzimmer das waren schlafzimmer von
nolte und da hatten wir richtig schöne
große schiebetüren richtig schön vor
allem mit einem glas spiegel davor
der nachteil war aber wenn du
zu zweit ist und beide gleichzeitig an
den schrank wollen muss einer ebene und
sehen also einer musste und sagen okay
ich warte es noch denn eine schiebetür
schiebt sich natürlich über die andere
hälfte drüber und das war einfach ein
bisschen kontraproduktiv dann hatten wir
den kleiderschrank mit ganz normalen
türen finde ich auch ganz praktisch aber
trotzdem habe ich mir gedacht komm lass
uns noch ein kleiderschrank nehmen ohne
türen staub ihn oder her das ist egal
den stopp muss man sowieso weg machen
und der kommt auch in den schrank aber
mit dem offenen kleiderschrank system
habe ich jetzt praktisch denn murat dazu
gezwungen ordentlich zu sein denn immer
wenn er die türe schließt und man ist
nicht mehr sieht ist also auf dem auge
aus dem sinn
das heißt da kann ich schon ordentlich
sein aber wir hier schon hinter mir seht
hier muss er wirklich seine ordnung
bewahren und deswegen haben uns diesmal
auch wenn ein kleiderschrank von leute
entschieden weil es einfach eine
superschwere tolle qualität ist das ist
regional die werden nur ein paar
kilometer von uns hier entfernt gebaut
und mein papa ist ganz stolz darauf denn
der papa früher weitergebaut und
gearbeitet hat alle kleiderschränke dort
aufgebaut
deswegen ist mein papa auch wirklich der
beste kleiderschrank aufbau aber diesmal
habe ich sagt mein vater hat schon
soviel kleiderschränke und küchen
aufgebaut unserem leben jetzt erspare
ihm die arbeit und da haben wir uns eben
einen kleiderschrank system von nolte
ausgesucht wie gesagt ohne türen
man kann aber auch wenn man sagt okay
ich möchte doch türen haben das später
immer noch dazu nehmen deswegen habe er
gesagt machen wir es jetzt erst mal ohne
und ich bin wirklich mit einer liste zum
lutz und habe mir gedacht okay ich
schreibe die liste auf schaut einfach
mal für was brauche ich stangen für was
brauche ich schubladen und ich möchte es
so wenig einlegeböden wie möglich wären
uns an unseren kleiderschrank
zusammengestellt ihn gestellt und auch
direkt liefern lassen mit den anderen
möbeln und eben auch vom team aufbauen
lassen und jetzt zeige ich euch wie ich
den kleiderschrank eingerichtet habe wir
haben jetzt wirklich diese beiden seiten
und habe nicht mehr platz als in unserer
alten wohnung das heißt ich habe zum hof
sagt murat alles was wir haben muss
wirklich hier reinpassen
es war trotzdem ein bisschen schwierig
im nachgang würde ich vielleicht ein
paar schubladen noch ändern und
einlegeböden austauschen aber das ist
auch das gute an dem system
ich gucke mir das jetzt einfach noch an
mich so zurecht komme und wenn ich sag
mensch braucht doch noch eine schublade
kann ich mir einfach noch eine schublade
nachbestellen oder eine stange
nachbestellen das ist dann wirklich
super individuell also das finde ich
schon ziemlich praktisch
also wir uns jetzt hier so aufgeteilt
murat ist hier sally ist da deswegen
zeige ich euch okay hier oben ist auch
noch sally aber das ist nur die wall
morata ähnlich drankommt das heißt ich
habe sagt die oberen fächer die kann ich
ja auch noch mit benutzen falls er nicht
so viel da pullover hat wer bis jetzt so
ein bisschen aufgeteilt jetzt gerade von
der jahreszeit herbst winter das heißt
die sommerklamotten habe ich jetzt auch
weg geräumt die sind oben eingeräumt und
ich hab das auch wirklich in allen
schränken so dass ich unten auf
augenhöhe die leisten habe also diese
stangen zum aufhängen weil du das ja
jeden tag brauchst und weiter oben was
man nicht so oft braucht das sind
einfach sachen die weggeräumt werden
also jetzt momentan so die sommersachen
und frühsommer wechsele ich das ganze
eben wieder
normalerweise bin ich kein fan von
einlegeböden aber jetzt gerade bei
pullovern bietet sich an weil viele
pullover gerade dieser stricksachen die
hängen sich zu sehr aus wenn man sie auf
hängt gerade wenn man es auch nass
aufhängt daher wird es hier gelegt und
wir haben hier den kleiderschrank auch
so ein bisschen an schrägen lassen damit
man einfach wenn man ins bad läuft nicht
so eine stolperfalle hat für den kleinen
zeh also deswegen ist ganz praktisch vor
allem kann man hier die pullover lagern
oder zum beispiel auch taschen oder
kisten und deswegen hat der moratti auf
seine dicken pullover tja dann stange
die ist hier so auf augenhöhe also seine
stange nach ich mache mich nicht darüber
lustig aber seine stangen sind einfach
etwas tiefer als meine weil ich eben
weiter hoch kommen und was sie hier auch
haben ist überall so etwas kann man das
praktisch raus drehen und dann eben auch
mal raus hinhängen und auch mal einen
tag hängen lassen wenn man es braucht
und dann wirklich einfach wieder
zurückdrehen und dann ist alles verstaut
und bei den kleiderbügeln da können da
wirklich ganz viel platz sparen wenn ihr
in die kleiderbügel nimmt so wie diese
hier und ich zeige euch eben auch gleich
wie ihr nicht nur beim kleiderschrank
einräumen platz sparen könnt und
arbeitszeit sparen könnt sondern
wirklich direkt auch schon beim waschen
weil da fängt es eigentlich an
da fängt die hausarbeit und wenn ihr so
einen übersichtlichen kleiderschrank
habt dann findet ihr zum einen alles
immer es geht alles ordentlich aus ihr
habt nichts was im schrank umlegt und
nichts an nicht angezogen wird und ihr
habt wirklich viel mehr platz der morath
der trägt wie gesagt eher so poloshirts
irgendwie immer schwarz dann hat er hier
noch ein paar hemden
hier auch und hier hat er jetzt dickere
kleiderbügel sind aus holz
weil ich da einfach die ganzen geheißen
die die ganzen westen drauf habe und die
anzugsjacke usw
dass das einfach nicht zerknittert und
eben doch ein bisschen stabiler ist
hier direkt unter den händen da hat er
seine schubladen
ich hoffe dass jetzt nichts dagegen aber
ich zeige sich jetzt einfach ich habe
ich seine unterwäsche also seine
boxershorts die gürtel und die socken
und ich für vorzugsrecht immer die
sachen hochkant reinzustellen
das heißt das war nicht ich und das war
ich auch nicht egal ich steckt aber
wieder so zurück denn dann sieht man
wirklich auf einen blick was man drin
hat und körper boxershorts habt ihr weg
ist den vorteil
sie zeige ich mal wie ich die falte also
die lege ich so zur hälfte und dann wird
im prinzip alles aufgerollt so wie so
ein kleines päckchen und dann kann man
sich hier reinstellen ohne dass das
ganze eben unübersichtlich wird und hier
weiter unten
da hat er seine jogginghosen drin die
wahrscheinlich aber nicht vollständig
sind und da macht das am besten auch so
die jogginghose halbieren dann noch mal
zur hälfte legen und hier auf rollen und
alles was ihr aufrollt könnt ihr dann
wunderbar so hinein stellen fällt nichts
und es passt vielmehr ein
also hatte moratti wie gesagt so einen
meter für seine kleiderstange so einfach
im sommer die sachen ausgetauscht werden
da kommen dann die lange sachen weg und
daher auch mehr t shirts im sommer dann
kommen die dahin
dann geht es hier weiter ich hätte noch
mal so eine halbe stange und zwar für
schwere dinge also schwere dinge heißt
für mich wirklich so ein pullover oder
so ein pullover jacken aber unsere
dicken winterjacken und alles ist aber
alles unten in der garderobe auch schuhe
zum beispiel weil wir auch daheim keine
schuhe tragen deswegen habe ich sagt
schur kam für mich nicht in den
kleiderschrank sondern wirklich in die
garderobe wenn man platz hat wenn nicht
muss man es klar irgendwo lagern und
deswegen hat er hier noch platz für so
dickere sachen und auch hier hat er dann
wirklich im sommer den platz für t
shirts zum beispiel
und dann hat er hier ein richtig cooles
tool das dreht sich hier nämlich und da
hängen seine krawatten
ich werde seine ohren sie sind auch noch
ein paar uhren mit drin so gut die uhr
funktioniert hier noch die verpackung
die macht des jammers selber unserer
sehr mag ja und hier sind sogar noch den
manschetten vom volkan team macht er
auch selbst also ihr seht warum lauter
kreative leute bei unserem team
da hat er noch ein paar fliegen man
traut dem nicht so aber der liebe morath
kannst es wirklich ganz schick anziehen
und wenn das dann umdreht dann hat er
einen spiegel
hallo es ist komisch news hier in meinem
kleiderschrank egal ich habe sie
gefunden die jogginghosen
aber komischerweise sind die noch nicht
sortiert also ihr seht hier sind sie
jetzt gerade so übereinander und man
findet nicht wirklich was deswegen zeige
ich euch jetzt das system wir machen wir
so eine art vorher nachher vorher
und jetzt machen wir das nachher und es
wird wie gesagt alles aufgerollt ach
jetzt weiß ich was der fehler war
wir haben nämlich hier seine badehosen
die badehosen die tu ich jetzt runter
die kommen unten gleich rein und die
jogginghosen die hole ich hoch der hat
wirklich sechs schwarze badehosen und
manchmal trägt das ist aber übereinander
denn es könnte ja sein dass aus wurst
also auch die kurzen sachen einfach so
ein bisschen einschlagen wie so eine
gerade linie und auf rollen und so finde
ich dann auch mega praktisch gerade für
den koffer zum beispiel wenn man
wirklich mal verreist geht nix auf und
man findet alles gleich das kombinieren
[Musik]
und habe ich die nicht gewünscht meine
oder manchmal bin ich mir selbst nicht
sicher
herr größer 36 dass ich meine kurze hose
kein wunder hatte ich dieses jahr nicht
an murat mensch das musste da hoch zu
den sommersachen na ja das mache ich
gleich aber guckt man jetzt mal wirklich
vorher nachher und ihr habt einfach viel
viel mehr platz und es ist alles
übersichtlicher ihr seht welche hose wo
ist und ist wirklich sehr platzsparend 1
konnte ich dem rat nicht ausreden und
das ist dieser hosen auszog
ich find ihn ja übersichtlich und
ordentlich und dem rad kann einfach die
hosen so drüber hängen und es ist glaube
ich auch wirklich von vorteil wenn man
so ein hosen aufhänger hat gerade wenn
man hosenanzüge haut dann verkehrt dort
einfach nix aber ich muss als echte zu
sagen ich habe ein paar hosen mehr dem
murat rechts und der markt ist auch das
mega zufrieden für mich wäre das ist
keine option weil einfach meine ganzen
hosen nicht drauf passen würden aber er
hat wirklich so alles im blick und vor
allem bleibt bei ihm alles schön
übersichtlich
ich hätte sogar noch einfach wo er zum
beispiel den gürtel drauflegen könnte
oder noch andere kleine gegenstände wie
uhren auch und er ist echt mega
zufrieden
dann habe ich hier noch sonne tritt
damit wir eben wenn hier oben dinge sind
gut hochkommen
der steht hierbei monats walter ebner
öfter den tritt auch als ich aber wie
gesagt gerade wenn ich auch schwere
sachen hier runter holen muss dann ist
es ganz praktisch und dann haben wir
hier nochmal dieses angeschrägte aus und
fach und da hat er einfach seine hüte
drin oder seine schals hier natürlich
seine ganzen kapuzen die hatte alle hier
die supermacht die kennt ihr und auch
noch die arbeitskleidung wobei für murat
ist immer alles arbeitskleidung also
wenn er draußen irgendwie baggert er
sich nicht extra arbeitsplätze an
sondern sind ganz normale sachen an und
dann muss jemand schimpfen weil dann
immer die ganze waschmaschine schmutzig
ist und alles so vermischt also hat hier
noch arbeitskleidung und sogar einen
sport rucksack der kommt nur leider
nicht so oft zum einsatz
ja aber das war jetzt hier so moratz
kleiderschrank und jetzt gehen wir über
zu meinem kleiderschrank
ach was wir auch haben hier außen wir
haben ja praktisch diese offenen schrank
front und hierauf hat dann einfach noch
so einfach da gibt es diese einlegeböden
aufhänger es gibt auch noch schalen die
man dran machen kann jetzt bei morath
hier nicht weil er einfach keinen
schmuck habt und ja da einfach seine
taschen noch mit dran oder gerade für
die reise diese kosmetik beutel
ja das wort häufig gesucht bei mir
drüben sieht es ein bisschen anders aus
ich habe im prinzip drei kleiderstangen
weil einfach die sachen die ich trage
oft gebügelt werden müssen wie zum
beispiel meiner karohemden meine kleider
meine bluse meine oberteile und dahin
geht einfach schon direkt nach der
wäsche auf im prinzip sollte ich euch
jetzt wahrscheinlich erst mal zeigen wie
ich meine wäsche machen und dann den
kleiderschrank denn das war logisch ich
gehe zwar mit euch in den wäscheraum und
zeigt euch mal wie bei uns die wäsche
organisiert wird und wie ich so ganz
ganz viel zeit im alltag sparen hier ist
unsere hauswirtschaftsraum und wir
hatten vorher und ich habe es 60 gehabt
wir hatten immer erst mal nur eine
wäsche tonne
da wird dann die ganze schmutzwäsche
reingeschmissen und einmal in der woche
da war mir damals noch zu zweit habe ich
schon immer die wäsche sortiert und die
partie war ein zwar noch in unserer
ersten wohnung und musste praktisch so
weiße wäsche helle bunte dunkle bunte
schwarze wäsche handtücher immer
aussortieren und dann haben wir schon in
der zweiten wohnung uns mehrere
wäschekörbe zugelegt das heißt sanierer
und anna wussten dann schon okay bund
kommt zur bund schwarz zu schwarz und so
weiter und haben jetzt einen richtig
schönen raum den zeige ich euch aber ein
anderes mal aber ich habe ich es
wirklich schon so dass ich im alltag
zeit spare denn ich habe hier vier
einwurf schächte weiß hell dunkel und
schwarz ab hier oben noch ein fach für
handtücher und hier noch für handwäsche
weil ich eben auch einige sachen habe
die man eben per hand waschen muss bzw
einfach im handwerk programm und dann
geht es nämlich ganz einfach und ich
habe jetzt gerade kaum wäsche aber
schwarz könnte jetzt gewaschen werden
dann stelle ich das hier drauf die jeans
kommt jetzt auch zu schwach das passt
und dann im prinzip gleich waschen und
wenn die wäsche gleich fertig ist zeige
ich euch wie ich sie gleich zeit sparend
direkt weiterverarbeitet
ich mache das thema automatik sanft denn
ich hab hier so'n eidos system das heißt
ich muss einmal nur meine waschmaschine
aufladen mit unserem waschmittel und
dann muss ich nichts mehr machen ich hab
jetzt nämlich ein bisschen weniger
welche drin und dann benutzt einfach
weniger waschmittel weniger wasser und
ist auch demnächst gleich fertig dann
sind wir jetzt wieder zurück bei mir und
wie gesagt habe ich die meisten sachen
die ich trage auf der stange und ich
habe ich jetzt momentan so hier sind
eher die kurzen sachen das heißt einfach
nur oberteile
der see ist jetzt sommer oder eben
kurzarm dh es sind auch dinge die ich im
winter trage mit cardigans drüber und
die anderen sommerkleider bzw sommer
oberteile und hosen habe ich jetzt erst
mal da oben gelagert weil eben der
sommer vorbei ist und hier habe ich
jetzt die herbst winter sachen also
alles was langsam ist und ich habe so
einen kleinen farbkübel das heißt ich
vor thema alles so dass von links nach
rechts und hell nach dunkel gilt denn
dann geht auch nicht unter und ich habe
würde ich jetzt mal sagen nicht so mega
viele kleider als es dann wirklich
sachen die ich wirklich immer trage bin
ich aber mal sagt okay ich will meinen
kleiderschrank ausmisten und ich weiß
nicht wo ich anfangen soll dann gibt es
den tipp
ich habe wirklich immer alle
kleiderbügel so im schrank hängen und
dann könnt ihr folgendermaßen vorgehen
ihr sortiert den kleiderschrank
ihr wisst aber noch nicht was sie auch
dorthin wollt also könnt ihr alles was
ihr getragen habt und gewaschen habt
dann so um hinein hängen
das sieht man auch hier oben und dann
seht ihr nach ungefähr 12 monaten oder
eben auch nach der jahreszeit also nach
dem winter oder nach dem sommer was habe
ich denn getragen und was habe ich nicht
getragen und dann können wir überlegen
trage ich es im nächsten jahr oder trag
ich es nicht kann ich es aussortieren
oder vielleicht einfach weiter
verschenken und dann bist du einfach was
bei euch im schranken so ein staubfänger
ist und was auf jeden fall weg kann
jetzt werde ich wahrscheinlich einfach
jetzt nach dem winter mal machen bzw
jetzt während der winterzeit und guck
einfach was ich trage und was nicht
allgemein finde ich alles was man auf
hängt immer ordentlicher weil man
wirklich alles nicht so sehr bügel muss
und dass zerknittert nicht vor allem t
shirts oder diese blusen die würden
einfach wenn ich sicher auch auf rolle
zu ergattern
und hier habe ich jetzt eine schublade
da habe ich auch die sachen drin die ich
jeden tag braucht zum beispiel meine
tops die habe ich meist unter den händen
an oder hat einfach diese bodies die
sind auch einfach farblich sortiert und
ich stelle immer alles rein also
normalerweise kennt man es ja dass die
oberteile dann so im kleiderschrank
legen dann nimmt man sich was raus dann
geht es wieder auf was alles von vorne
wieder zusammenlegen
und wenn ihr alles in ihrem
kleiderschrank hochkant reinlegt dann
klappt es echt viel besser und es bleibt
ordentlicher und dasselbe ziel wie ihr
seht einfach so tecops dem man so
drunter hat ich halte die einfach so
dass die ärmlichen hütten sind dann
kommt es hier rein dann habe ich hier
einen schönen abschluss und entweder
dann drittel oder viertel bei dem
wirklich selbst weil es ziemlich breit
ist und hab dann wie so ein kleines
päckchen mit diesem geschlossenen rand
und das wird dann hier reingestellt und
dann kann man sich wirklich was raus
nehmen ohne dass alles andere
zusammenbricht
ich habe ich noch diese aufteilungen
drin die gibt es entweder das so auch
direkt zu kaufen oder man kann sie sich
die aus holz oder aus karton basteln und
da habe ich einfach socken strumpfhosen
und meine kuschel socken drin da unten
habe ich dann noch die offenen fächern
also in meiner handtasche drin und da
habe ich einfach gar nicht so viele
ich habe immer eine kleine handtasche
die habe ich unten in der garderobe das
ist die idee ich so jeden tag hab mich
dann doch eine besondere handtasche will
dann gehe ich einfach hier dran dann
geht es hier zu den langen sachen da
habe ich meine kleider drin oder auch
cardigans hier ganz links habe ich
schrecke die habe ich jetzt auch
hingehängt weil ich den platz habt wenn
ich jetzt keinen platz gehabt hätte
würde ich die einfach zu den hosen mit
reinlegen
das variiert so ein bisschen immer
zwischen sommer und winter im sommer
hängt nämlich viel mehr und im winter
habe ich ein bisschen mehr platz und
hier habe ich dann auch einfach meine
kleider drin die ich so im herbst winter
an habt oder auch meine besonderen
kleider die ich mal zu anlässen an
habe ich muss echt sagen ich bin ein
kleiner mädchen ich sehr gerne kleider
an
aber irgendwie doch so selten ja ja ja
und was habe ich hier noch und hier habe
ich noch so ein offenes fach denn ich
weiß nicht ob es aber am abend oder am
nachmittag wenn ich dann so feierabend
habt dann ziehe ich irgendwie gerne so
kuschel gammelt vermuten an
das heißt für mich ich brauche dann halt
so einfach wo ich auch mal keine an so
ein pullover reinlegen kann den ich
jetzt gestern abend an hatte da ist aber
noch zu frisch für die wäsche aber so
zur frischen wünsche will ich ihn auch
nicht legen also habe ich hier so ein
offenes fach wurde es dann hier
reinlegen kann und kann es da noch heute
benutzen und dann eben erst in die
wäsche geben so ein paar kleider habe
ich schon wo ich sagen trage ich die
noch mal oder nicht da brauche ich ab
und zu etwas hat den rat von moralisch
oder von jemand anderem
naja was ich euch hier noch zeigen will
auf jeden fall ist mein spiegel denn ihr
fragt euch bestimmt wenn du keine türen
hast wo ist dein spiegel
hier ist da und den kann man hieraus
klappen hallo
und da wirklich noch mal ein ganz ganz
großes dankeschön an den thorsten damit
den kleiderschrank hier aufgebaut hat
vom xxl lutz
denn er hatte die mega geniale idee ich
hatte dass nämlich eigentlich hier
eingeplant debatte wo anders der war
irgendwo anders eingeplant ich glaube
hier und erst kommt der liebe machen das
hier hin denn dann kannst du murats
drews dreht schrank hier noch benutzen
und wenn man dann fährt kann man
wirklich so sich auch von hinten
betrachten als hätten sie das machen
würde aber manchmal zieht mal was an
müll gucken wie sie das hinten und vorne
aus und jetzt haben wir hier praktisch
die zwei spiegel gegenüber legend und
was haben sich eben 360° betrachten und
das war die idee vom thorsten also
vielen dank nochmal für den aufbau das
war echt mega cool
ja als auch die unterwäsche die habe ich
da unten drin
ich hätte gerne etwas höher gehabt aber
ich hatte leider oben keinen platz die
zeige ich euch jetzt nicht dass ich
bisschen komisch finde ich wenn ich ja
könnt euch jetzt angestoßen hier
irgendwo über habe ich noch einfach aber
ich könnte zwar nicht tauschen
das mache ich noch mal nach dem
videodreh tausche ich dieses fach mit
diesem ja hier habe ich noch
dieser kleine täschchen mit drin und
geldbeutel gut ich habe nur einen
geldbeutel denn ersatz geldbeutel und
ansonsten habe ich hier noch meine
kittel die ich hier zusammengerollt habe
meine sonnenbrillen und einfach nur
diese schals und da finde ich echt diese
unterteilung ganz gut wenn man hat doch
irgendwie als frau aber auch als man
finde ich so ein paar kleinen kurs
sachen die gerne mal in seiner schublade
untergehen und wenn ihr dann diese
unterteilung habt dann ist es echt ganz
praktisch
kommen wir zum bei dem spezialgerät ich
glaube dieses fach ist euch alle noch in
erinnerung als ich nämlich den schrank
eingeräumt habe habe ich damals gemacht
und gefragt wie viele karohemden besitze
ich und ich glaube so richtig kam keiner
drauf ihr habt alle untertrieben
ich hab echt fehle es war halt einfach
wo ist eigentlich mein allererstes hier
mein allererstes karohemd ist dieses
hier und es war halt einfach so mein
papa hat gesagt mensch mädchen das steht
jetzt so gut
und dann war das halt wenn es papa
gefällt dann ist es halt schön und vor
allem muss ich nicht überlegen was sehe
ich jeden tag an sondern ich sie einfach
eine hose ankara und drüber fertig habe
mir zeit zum kochen
ich habe ich meine karohemden und ich
komme so eigentlich auch ganz gut dran
aber ich habe hier auch noch eine stange
zum herbst da ziehen und so könnt ihr
dann wirklich auch dinge ganz hoch
aufhängen und den platz optimal
ausnutzen bis unter die decke ohne dabei
einen tritt benutzen zu müssen
und gerade jetzt beim aufhängen ist es
ganz praktisch und dann wird das hier
wieder nach oben transportiert war
meinen eltern drüben habe ich das
übrigens auch und das
ganz praktisch also das ist wirklich so
ein hilfsmittel das sehr sehr
vereinfacht und wenn man möchte könnte
man jetzt hier drunter nochmal eine
stange machen und dann wirklich noch mal
so eine enge fläche meine karre
kollektion
ich weiß nicht wie viele ich
mittlerweile habe ein paar sind noch auf
der wäscheleine
ich müsste man zähle hier unten habe ich
dann noch fächer
ja da war ich mir ein bisschen
unschlüssig soll ich fächer machen mache
ich noch mal schubladen hier habe ich
gedacht komm ich mache jetzt einfach mal
fächer die kann man auch immer mal gut
gebrauchen
und die sind wirklich schön unterteilt
da habe ich jetzt die dicken pullover
drin
im sommer habe ich da was hat sich daran
im sommer hatte ich glaube ich auch ein
paar t-shirts die dann eben nicht sofort
anfällig sind hatte ich noch drin und da
einfach wirklich immer so zusammen legen
dass er wirklich platzsparend dann hier
reinkommen
ja dieses stück das blau
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das gut findet
das ist meine trainingsjacke da gibt es
eine geschichte dazu
ich war nämlich eben anti castor das ist
übrigens keine bezahlter werbung denn
ich habe das selber bezahlt ich war das
tor hat mich mal eingedeckt mit schöner
kleidung der schon ein bisschen länger
her und dann sagt meine schwester ich
soll doch bitte mit samira beim marathon
mit machen nichts war ja kein problem
wir machen beim kinder marathon mit
kindern familien marathon ich mit meiner
neuen adidas kleidung das hatte ich
drüber eine hose hatte ich an und so ein
weißes oberteil geht dahin und die
samira hat hat ganz normale
sportkleidung und irgendwie war keiner
so geteilt wie ich denn alles was
schwarze sonne
ich habe keine ahnung warum das seiner
schwester was noch mal warum es in die
alles so sagte hey warum hat die
neuesten sachen an bisher marathon oder
und dann sagt sie ja dieser survival
lauf also dieses strong vikings nichts
drang vikings was ich streng vikings
jetzt wartet im tiefsten winter mussten
wird durch schlamm durch wasser durch
matsch durch alle mögliche hindernisse
drüber drunter ich gesagt ganz ehrlich
aber ich mach mich nicht nass aber es
ging schon beim ersten hindernis nicht
mehr
das ende vom lied war ich habe ein
vorher bild und ein nachher bis drei
kleidungsstücke kann ich leider nicht
mehr gebraucht
ich zeig dir jetzt die bilder okay also
was quasi diese wahl gelaufen nur die
jacke hat zu wollen nur die jacke hat
und ich war der einzige tipp der einzige
trottel mit neuer kleidung
alle anderen hatten einfach was alte
sohn von strong my case das ist die
geschichte zu meiner schönen adidas
kleidung also ich zeig dir jetzt mal vor
herne hier meine schwester mein schwager
samira und ich hier in meiner neuesten
3d vision zwischenstand dann einen
zwischenstand opfer habe ich hier noch
mit der kamera achtung
was für ein special effect ich mit der
kamera gemacht habe warte warte ich
komme gleich noch die kamera platziert
voll die action aufnahmen hier
und dann kamen leider sumpf und macho
okay das ist ja noch zeigen
vorwitzig
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
heute so witzig und hinterher sah ich
dann so aus und das war nachdem ich mich
sauber gemacht habe oh ja
die hose ist leider nicht mehr zu
gebrauchen und das weiße oberteile nicht
mehr das sagst du ich war richtig es war
am ende ich war voller matsch voller
schlamm und dann muss man noch mal ganz
zum schluss durchs wasser weil es dann
schwer wirklich gar nichts mehr gegangen
das war mein striking ja hier hier sagen
wir aus vor der wäsche waren völlig
kaputte die waren aber von meinem
schwager das war okay
dann habe ich hier nämlich noch eine
schublade das ist doch meine sport
schublade
man glaubt es kaum aber ich habe eine
sport schublade und auch die hat so
unterteilungen hier habe ich zum
beispiel die sind ganz praktisch weil
wir manchmal doch echt ein bisschen
unterwegs sind für den koffer
diese kleinen einlege taschen von bleibt
nämlich alles immer schön übersichtlich
und ich kann hier zum beispiel
wäschereien machen ihnen das andere fach
mache ich oberteile rein und dann
rutscht im koffer nichts hin und her
die habe ich bei der iris bekommen
meiner freunde hier habe ich dann meine
ganzen sport leggings und sportlich ging
es ist für mich klar eigentlich war es
so und sport macht aber die sind auch so
bequem dass ich dem alltag dann ab und
zu mal gerne trage und die mache ich
dann auch wirklich so dass ich sie
zuerst einmal halbieren so dann hier den
schritt nach innen falten halbieren und
dann wirklich nur noch auf rollen und so
sehe ich dann wirklich auch wieder auf
einen blick welche leggings möchte ich
tragen welche ist gerade damals und ist
gelangt nichts durcheinander
das hier sind oberteile die sind genauso
gerollt das zeige ich euch auch also
hier ein ganz normales mittlerweile
verwaschenes spott t shirt deshalb gehe
ich dann
klappe die ärmel ein damit sie immer
schön rechts und links alles schön
gerade ist und dann auch wieder
aufrollen und dann nutze ich einfach
immer die komplette breite des fachs aus
ich habe ich doch noch so kurze hosen
drin meine bikinis und noch so passau
natürlicher die brauche ich nämlich auch
wenn ich sport mache dann mache ich dann
immer das komplettprogramm und dann
komme ich jetzt zu meinem jeans war
ich organisiere meine jeans und meine
hosen hier in dieser schublade finde ich
mega praktisch vor allem weil ich
wirklich alles auf einen blick sehen und
es fällt nichts um
und da mache ich es wirklich so warte
mal ich suche eine aus der mitte aus
okay die ist echt ein schlechtes
beispiel wer hat dir eingestuft mein
gott oh gott da mach ich es auch so
nicht nehmen die hose halb ihr sie und
je nach länge der jeans wird sie dann
gedrittelt oder geviertelt so das sie
dann wirklich wenn man sich hinstellt
auch aufrecht steht also sowieso ein
kleines pack ich habe mal irgendwo
gelesen dass der durchschnittsdeutsche
neuen jeans hat ich hab 2 4 6 8 10 12 14
und staub sind tatsächlich alle
vielleicht habe ich noch eine
unterwäsche irgendwo aber mich würde mal
interessieren wie viele jeans oder hosen
habt ihr und es wirklich so ich habe
einfach so meine 213 die ich wirklich
sehr gerne trage und die trage ich dann
noch mehrere tage so ein oberteil trage
ich nur einmal aber hosen finde ich
meine so lange da nix drauf kommt finde
ich muss man nicht so oft waschen und da
habe ich echt nicht so viele und die
lieblinge die trag ich dann eben am
liebsten was ich hier noch habe weil
eben das fach auch so schön groß ist und
ich brauche wirklich nur das halbe fach
für meine jeans also anders als bei
moral
hier habe ich noch so meine gammel
klamotten drin ich habe tatsächlich drei
jogginghosen hier noch meine pullover
morath hast diesen pullover
aber da ist so süß guck dir denn an und
da steht drauf snow queen
wie kann man diesen pullover hast da ist
so kurz gelungen ich liebe dich mein
lieber pullover okay er sieht aus als
könnte da meine oma passen aber das ist
mein ganz ehrlich mit zu einer leggings
hunde ja aber er sagt immer das ist
nicht schön das sind liebestöter lieb
ist
man muss den pullover auch leben
aber er hat tatsächlich meine spongebob
schwammkopf flauschige fliesst hose
weggeschmissen
ok ich muss sozusagen die gab es nicht
in meiner länge also war das so eine
hochwasser in gelb mit ganz vielen
andern lassen drauf ananas bananen
ananas ananas oder weggeschmissen
einfach so das darf ja auch was von dem
wegschmeißen nein mache ich nicht und in
dem fach untendrunter habe ich noch so
war pitschnass kurze hosen oberteile und
hier noch meine steppwesten die ich
jetzt im winter auch immer ganz gern
trat und da ist auch so ihr könnt die
entweder wirklich ganz normal hier
einlegen oder aufhängen aber so habt ihr
einfach alles auf einen blick könnt euch
eine steppweste rausnehmen der rest
bleibt trotzdem schön sauber hier
drinnen und ihr habt wirklich keinen
platz verbraucht
das ist so der kleiderschrank und dann
sage ich euch noch hier das außen fach
und hier ist so meine stirnseite des
kleiderschranks ich schlafe auf dieser
webseite das heißt ich komme immer hier
direkt und habe den letzten gang zum bad
und haben deswegen auch unsere
bademäntel noch aufgehängt kenne ich
noch so kleine handtaschen und meine
handytasche guckt mal wie praktisch und
genial ist david und gerade wenn ich
sowas an habt ihr heute also ohne
hosentasche man will er das handy jedoch
immer bei sich haben
ich habe es jetzt auch weg gelegt weil
ich gerade drehe
dort habe ich hier einfach meine
handytasche danke ehre die er es hat
immer die coolsten sachen ja das ist so
eine handytasche aus recyceltem material
und hier habe ich oben einfach noch so
kleine handtaschen also so eine clutch
zum beispiel unten meine sporttasche die
auch etwas häufiger zum einsatz kommt
als moritz tasche dies auch immer
gepackt also dies immer bereit für zum
sport jetzt glaube ich ist die wäsche
fertig würde ich zeige euch mal wie ich
die wäsche noch aufhängen
da können wir wirklich wenn ihr da sagt
hayes handicap uns noch mehr coole tipps
für den alltag für zum wäschewaschen
aufhängen usw kinderzimmer fertig machen
dann schreibt mir gerne dann kann ich
euch da wirklich so meine alltagstipps
mit geben aber jetzt gucken wir uns mal
kurz nach der wäsche denn mein handy hat
schon geklingelt und mir ein signal
gegeben werde es fertig ich habe es
nämlich connected
fertig ok aber was hat denn da eine
leggins die wir natürlich gleich direkt
aufgehängt dass es dann wieder so ein
kleidungsstück war es zusammengefalteten
aufgerollt wird dies von samira und ich
habe jetzt hier einfach in meinem
wäscheraum direkt auf platz zum
aufhängen
hier ist ein murat t shirt
wenn man das so oft schleudert muss man
es meist nicht mal bündeln und dieses
werde jetzt direkt auf dem bügel gehängt
das heißt nach dem aufhängen und trocken
und habe ich wirklich keine arbeit mehr
damit und kannst dann einfach sofort in
seinen kleiderschrank reinhängen
da hat man es nur einmal in der hand und
hat keine arbeit meter mit das ist avira
follower von drachenzähmen leicht
gemacht und da probiere ich auch alles
so weit es geht als aufzuhängen bei den
kindern und die mädels die haben dann
noch unterschiedliche kleiderbügel das
heißt samira hat schwarze und ella hat
bunte usw
der monat dann auch wenn die wäsche
getrocknet ist was wohin gehört da kommt
nämlich bei den zwei nichts
durcheinander
die hänge ich immer gleich so auf also
gleich doppelt dauert zwar einen ticken
länger aber ich finde die trocknen dann
etwas glatte
okay weil den unterhosen wunsch nicht
mehr dabei sein
die und losen hätte ich so noch mit auf
und wir haben sie jetzt hier in unserem
schlafzimmer wirklich so hier vorne
steht das bett mit dem sideboard und
hinter dem bett ist der kleiderschrank
und das ist auch wirklich ganz praktisch
denn in der alten wohnung war das
nämlich so dass ich natürlich ich stehe
immer zuerst auf weil ich länger
brauchte schon haare föhnen und so
weiter ich stehe dann zuerst auf und
muss dann immer an den kleiderschrank
natürlich mit licht und aborte murat
immer wach und es war auch einer der
gründe warum wir den kleiderschrank hier
hinten haben denn ich stehe auf und
wärmer das smart home für loks das heißt
ich muss auch keine lichtschalter
betätigen ich stehe auf und laufe dann
geht hier unter dem bett ein kleines
licht am damit ich mich nicht an stoße
dann komme ich hier nach hinten
und hier geht wirklich nur an der decke
dann ein gedimmtes licht an und das habe
ich so eingestellt so dass ich gerade so
sehe was ich eben raus nehme und ich
meine ich kenne meinen kleiderschrank
ich weiß was so hängt und was ich
brauche und dann kann ich direkt ins bad
rüber das licht geht dann von alleine
wieder aus ich kann ins bad rüber und
fertigt award wird nicht gestört
das war also mein video zum
kleiderschrank und wenn ihr diese
einfachen tipps und tricks beachtet dann
spart ihr zum einen viel zeit in ihrem
arbeitsalltag und natürlich auch ganz
viel platz habt alles übersichtlicher
und wisst genau was hier ansehen könnt
und wollten was vielleicht aus ihrem
kleiderschrank verschwinden kann
der erste tipp ist also am besten alles
aufzuhängen was geht weil so die
kleidung wirklich schön faltenfrei
bleibt ihr spar durch die zeit die ihr
normalerweise zum zusammenlegen hättet
und ihr spart euch die zeit beim bügeln
ein weiterer tipp ist er schubladen zu
benutzen als einlegeböden denn in
schubläden findet man alles ein bisschen
übersichtlicher weil man einfach den
boden ausziehen kann man hat alles auf
einen blick von oben und man kann alles
sowohl jeans als auch leggings
unterhosen oder auch socken schild
zusammenrollen und übersichtlich
gestalten wenn ihr doch etwas ausmisten
wollt dann trägt doch einfach die
kleiderhaken um so seht ihr wirklich
nach dass es so was ihr getragen habt
und was nicht und das was ihr nicht
getragen habt könnt ihr weiter schenken
oder eben irgendwo hin spenden
die kleidungsstücke die am meisten
treibt verwahrte am besten auf augenhöhe
auf und das was seltener getragen wird
er weiter unten wo ihr euch dann eben
selten nach witten müsst und das was ihr
gerade gar nicht braucht dass man doch
ganz nach oben
denn da ist der stauraum wo man eben am
seltensten drankommt im allgemeinen ist
es auch immer besser die kleidung
hochkant in die schubladen reinzulegen
als übereinander zu stapeln
weil man so auf einen blick sieht was
drin steckt und was man raus ziehen
möchte
in den schubladen kannst du besser
ordnung halten wenn du einteilungen hass
und wenn diese nicht im schrank
mitgeliefert werden kannst du sie ganz
einfach aus holz oder aus kartons selbst
basteln die meiste zeit sparst du
übrigens im alltag beim wäschewaschen
wenn du die wäsche die sowieso auf bügel
kommt direkt nach der waschmaschine auf
die bügel hengst trocknen lässt und dann
einfach nur noch in den schrank in
münster ein offener kleiderschrank
zwingt dich quasi zur ordnung denn wenn
die türen hast ist zwar alles schön
verschlossen aber da kann sich auch
gerne mal ein bisschen was an sammeln
was eben nicht mehr ganz so ordentlich
ist der nachteil von einem offenen
kleiderschrank ist natürlich dass alles
etwas schneller ein stoppt das heißt da
muss man einfach ein bisschen öfter
staubwischen
ich finde es relativiert sich aber so
ein bisschen denn ansonsten müsste man
die kleider schranktüren auswischen
ich hoffe euch hat dieses wieder
gefallen falls ihr noch fragen habt dann
schreibt sie gerne in die kommentare
und wenn ihr wissen wollt was ich in
meinem hauswirtschaftsraum noch so alles
habe schreibt auch gerne rein gerne eure
ganzen fragen die wäsche routine was
auch immer ihr sehen möchtet ich würde
das gerne für euch also viel spaß beim
umrüsten ihres kleiderschranks und bis
zum nächsten markt ist und vielleicht
habt ihr ja auch noch den einen oder
anderen tipp den ich nicht wusste
dann schreibt auch gerne in die
kommentare bis bald
so jetzt kommen um politik und zwar laut
studie ist es wirklich so dass nur 20
prozent der kleidung kleiderschrank auch
welch getragen werden die anderen dinge
sind irgendwie zusammengeknüllt irgendwo
in den ecken drin oder die ziehst du
vielleicht an einmal in zwei jahren
und deswegen ist es wichtig den
kleiderschrank tier regelmäßig
auszumisten und was ich auch kraß finde
ist dass 30 prozent der klein und es ist
der wahnsinn
30 prozent der kleinen kleiderschrank um
getragen ist das heißt man kauft sich
welche kleidungsstücke schweizer einfach
rein hat die nie angezogen und dafür
habe ich einen ganz ganz coolen tipp
damit habe ich schon mal die sally
manipuliert und das funktioniert
wirklich unserer folgenden tipp wenn ihr
einkaufen geht und kleidung kaufen dann
und des kleidungsstückes anschaut dann
muss es immer das beste kleidungsstück
in eurem kleiderschrank sein das heißt
das was er kauft wenn es anschaut sagt
boah das ist das genial stick leider
stück in meinem schrank und nun dann
solltet ihr es kaufen und mit diesem
trick habe ich schon einen haufen geld
gespart weil jedes mal richtig sie
irgendwo wenn es war das einkaufen nicht
selten einkaufen muss ich sagen ein
gutes ding angesagt ist das das schönste
kleidungsstück aus meinem kleiderschrank
und diese fragen können sich meistens
nicht beantworten da möchte ich einfach
weiter das ist ein cooler pula schwarzen
trikot
und weil er klein natürlich auch darauf
achten qualität vor quantität lieber ein
paar coole basic so bin ich zum beispiel
die meisten meiner klamotten sind
arbeitsklamotten habe glaube ich meine
frau gemeldet sie mal wegschmeißen ich
habe auch schon zwei drei jacken aus dem
mülheimer rausgeholt
ich zeige ich mal ganz kurz meine jacke
ihr müsst euch ganz kurz zeigen bitte
bleibt
roth familie durch seinen überraschenden
ähnlich
ja genau wie die meisten okay ich finde
sie wieder hat sie mal ich weiß wo sie
ist
hier ist nicht aber ich finde sie gleich
ich habe jetzt kann nach meiner jacke
gesucht die seine frau immer
wegschmeißen weil sie so so widerlich
findet wenn ihr mal locker drin die habe
ich schon seit 15 jahren und ich habe
auch schon geflickt und einen drohen
kann ich meine lieblings sagen das ist
so wie batmans cape sozusagen das ist
reine glückssache
jetzt habe ich sie gerade gesucht welche
sich seit wochen nicht angezogen habe
jetzt hat sie wieder weggeschmissen
jetzt müssen wir versuchen auf jeden
fall gibt es ein paar kleidungsstücke
hier sind einfach meine lieblings
kleidungsstücke dass sich auch zeigen
dass da hier zum beispiel bis da das ist
mein artist ist der wahnsinn was ich in
meinem leben schon mit dieser hose alles
gemacht habe
wahnsinn oder
das ist so richtig die haben geschichten
damit habe ich da habe ich schon rein
geschwitzt aber ich habe es auch
gewaschen
aber das ist sowieso eine hose wo ich
einfach die könnte ich niemals
wegschmeißen und auf jeden fall
übertreibt es nicht erträgt nur 20
prozent teurer kleidung kleiderschrank
das heißt ab und zu mal aus müssen auf
qualität achten natürlich wenn es
möglich ist bei euch und ja das war halt
eine tipp wird euch ein haufen geld
sparen